[Music]
this week on forward
but my book it barely has any stories of
people being fired or canceled because I
think for the stakes go well beyond that
they go to questions like how our
children are educated how we are
encouraging the next generation of
Americans to see themselves and to see
each other I don't want a society in
which every person is leaning more into
their sort of tribal self-interest and
why it's join the game and say great
we're going to be proud white people
fighting for our interests that sounds
to me like a description of a terribly
deeply divided Society
[Music]
it is my pleasure to welcome back to the
podcast the author of the brand new the
identity trap a story of ideas and Power
in our time writer for the Atlantic
Johns Hopkins Professor Yasha monk
welcome back Yasha Andrew I look forward
to talking with you about this book
yeah we had you on a couple years ago
talking about your last book the great
experiment about democracy and you
actually hinted at the themes of the
identity trap in that book uh but you've
delved in headlong and I dare say this
is something that is really imperative
um there's been this fascinating
progression over the last number of
years where uh and you catalog it
painstakingly in the identity trap uh
where what you call the identity
synthesis has risen an overrun Academia
and media institutions and non-profits
and other things but now there is this
kind of wait a minute is this really
what we want is this really working what
is it
and so your book strikes me as very very
uh timely thank you yeah I mean you know
I am by training and intellectual
historian and a political theorist not
just being struck but over the last
decades we've seen the emergence of this
genuinely new ideology which is very
different from previous strains of
laughtering food and then in this
breathtaking moment in about the course
of a decade these ideas came to have
incredible purchase on mainstream
institutions in the United States from
universities to non-profit organizations
to religious communities and
corporations and uh I'm struck by the
fact that very few people have actually
paused to understand those ideas say
where are these ideas actually coming
from how do they become so powerful and
are they a good idea or not so that's
what I'm doing in in the new book and
the identity trap for first part tells
me very interesting story of the
theorists who are sort of came up with
these ideas and how these ideas came to
coalesce the second part of a story
tells the story of how these ideas went
from being influential in corners of the
academy but pretty marginal to society
as a whole to having this mainstream
purchase this mainstream influence for
third part of a book really
criticizes the application of these
ideas to areas like free speech and
cultural appropriation and all those
other kinds of things we've been
discussing and debating in the last
years and finally I make a case for how
we can take discrimination seriously
take racism and homophobia and Injustice
seriously but hold on to what I think is
good in other political Traditions hold
on in particular to the basic
Universalist aspirations of our system
of government so this is a book that
criticizes these ideas but it does so in
a serious way without polemic
um and that takes them seriously I agree
with the case you're making by the way
just to let everyone know
so
um so let's identify what we're talking
about so you call it the identity
synthesis others might call it wokeness
others might call it political
correctness I'm going to call out two
authors who have tackled this in
different ways John McWhorter the
Columbia Professor called it woke racism
which was I thought very very
provocative uh name he gave it Tim Urban
in his book what's our problem
I talked about in a certain way so how
would you
Define the identity synthesis
yeah so first of all I don't really
know what to call it I think it's ready
to boa who said just just tell me what
on Earth to call this thing and I'll
take I'll use that name but I think it's
a problem that we don't have a neutral
appellation for this right in America
some people are socialists lots of
people is like socialism some people are
conservatives lots of people dislike
conservatism but but everybody can agree
to call it socialism socialism to call
conservatism conservatism right you're
not sort of spiking the ball we're
spiking the football by calling it one
thing or the other and in this area we
don't have a term that is neutral that
supporters and critics of this tradition
can agree on and it's really made it
harder to think through and talk about
it so I'm calling it The identity
synthesis because this is a new set of
ideas about race and gender and sexual
orientation
um and it is I believe a synthesis of
different intellectual influences in uh
postmodernism postcolonialism and
finally critical race Theory feel free
to call it something else call it the
thing but I think we needed term for it
so you're asking you know what actually
defines that and you know there's been
some debate about that there's been a
viral clip of somebody not being able to
Define it and so some people say well
there's no such thing as workers we
don't even know what it is no I think we
can Define it one way to define it is
through the main themes of ideas that
people coalesce around it is a
skepticism towards Grand narratives
including that which sustains our basic
institutions in the American Republic it
is a politicized form of discourse
critique which thinks of political
Battle of political engagement of
consisting a lot not in fights over
policies but in fighting over cultural
hegemony of how we talk about things
that part of feminist politics is to
debate and to praise or to critique the
Barbie movie it is the Embrace of a form
of what Gayatri spivako strategic
essentialism which acknowledges that
race is a social construct prevents us
for political purposes we should
actually be encouraging our children to
be racial beings to think of themselves
as strongly as possible in racial terms
it is a rejection of universal solutions
to problems which is rooted in the the
the work of critical race Fury saying
that we should reject the the fund
Racial equality ideology of the Civil
Rights Movement make how people are
treated explicitly depend of a group of
which were a part and finally it is a
deep skepticism about our ability to
understand each other across the lines
of identity a skepticism about the ways
in which members of different groups can
actually communicate so those are the
the basic themes another way of getting
at this is to boil this ideology down to
its free core claims now nobody has made
exactly those three claims in those ways
this is sort of an exercise in what
philosophers called rational
reconstruction of retrying to boil a
rich complicated tradition with many
themes down to its core ideas but I
think it's a useful exercise now it's a
bit of three main claims associated with
this tradition are the following ones
number one but to understand the world
you really have to look at it you really
have to see it through the prism of
identity groups like race gender and
sexual orientation that's what's going
to explain big historical events and
it's going to explain how we relate to
each other in this conversation
secondly that the Bill of Rights and the
Declaration of Independence and all of
those Universal aspirations all of us
neutral rules
it didn't actually aim to make the world
a better place they were designed to
pull the wool over people's eyes to
actually perpetuate racial
discrimination sexual discrimination
other forms of Injustice and then
finally the upshot of that if you want
to make progress in the future it is not
a matter as Frederick Douglass and
Martin Luther King Jr and others
believed of living up
to the promises of the Constitution of
making sure that every American actually
enjoys the protection of him it is
discarding them it is getting rid of
them it is making explicitly depend uh
on the group to which you belong how I
treat you you treat me how the state
treats all of us
imagine running for president and
wanting to share what you experienced in
a way that's entertaining edifying and
maybe even a little bit scary that's the
last election out in bookstores now a
novel about Independent presidential
candidate a journalist with a massive
story and what the heck could be our
next slash last election check it out at
andrewyang.com
[Music]
yeah the the book opens with various
accounts of children being corned off by
race in the classroom uh some of them in
schools that I recognize I have two
school-aged children and it's been
interesting as a parent trying to figure
out how to explain race uh to your your
kids but I will say I'd be deeply
uncomfortable if I knew that they were
just showing up and being like hey like
you're in this uh classroom or group
you're in this classroom or group just
based explicitly on on on how they look
or their ethnic background
um so for for folks who have looked at
this and and this I think people do
understand uh why is this such an
important thing to tackle and and you
talk about in the book a little bit you
say look and this is one of the problems
of our time where it's like this is both
sides of them it's like hey why are you
Reckoning with like Quantum quote the
excesses uh of the left when the real
danger is uh is from the other side
which just something that you do touch
on and I think it's one of the problems
of this kind of binary uh political
world we live in where it's like you
know two sides to everything like hey if
you do this with us why aren't you doing
it over there
um I I happen to think this is a serious
problem it takes us away from actually
solving the problems it takes us away
from uh core issues it does also
occasionally ruin people's careers uh it
silences a ton of people like there are
a lot of folks who feel like they can't
actually speak their mind for fear of
getting drummed out of a particular
institution but why should people be
most concerned I guess I gave my list
yeah you answered your own question
better than I can so now I'm in a bad
position but let me say a few things
right I mean first of all you know I I'm
not against any form of identity
politics there's certain forms of what
might be called identity politics that's
perfectly appropriate it's fine for
there to be the AARP fighting for the
interests of older Americans even for
sometimes the power that that group has
is not for the best uh you know it's
perfectly normal that when you were
running your presidential campaign you
probably had some forms of targeted
Outreach to Asian Americans I think
that's perfectly fine but it's a normal
way of doing politics so I'm not worried
about kids uh understanding in certain
ways that were part of an ethnic group
and where that structures however
treated in society but what we're
talking about here is a much more
extreme form of that right what we're
talking about is Teachers coming into
first second great classrooms and saying
if you're white you go over there if
you're Asian you go over here if you
Latino you go over there if you're black
you go over there and that is imposing
an identity on them and this new uh
Progressive ideology of pedagogy
explicitly leans into that one of the
most influential organizations now in
that space is called embrace race
and schools whether it's Bank School uh
Bank Street School in the Upper West
Side of Manhattan or Dalton on the Upper
East Side uh silver friends and Horace
Mann and other elite private schools
explicitly want to teach their children
to think of themselves as quote unquote
racial beings I think that that goes too
far and I worry about what's going to
happen to the white kids I don't worry
that they might be uncomfortable or
something like that I think being
uncomfortable is a good part of
Education sometimes but if you tell
those kids to Quinn could own the
European Heritage to think of themselves
in racial terms as whites a few of them
might become anti-racist activists a few
of them might start to disown the white
privilege a lot of them are going to do
what is unfortunately very human to say
if that is my primary group I'm gonna
fight for the interests of that group
I'm gonna treat people within that group
better and people outside of that group
worse and then you've created white
supremacists which is the last thing
that we need in our politics so I think
this starts to illustrate some of the
reasons why we should care about this
one is simply that this has real Stakes
um you know you mentioned people being
fired or being canceled and I worry
about that and I've written about that
but my book it barely has any stories of
people being fired or canceled because I
think for the stakes go well beyond that
they go to questions like how our
children are educated how we are
encouraging the next generation of
Americans to see themselves and to see
each other they go to important
questions of public policy during the
pandemic for example a key advisory
Council to the CDC refused to prioritize
elderly Americans for scarce anti-covet
vaccines even though the cdc's own
models showed that this would was the
most effective way to save lives why did
they refuse to do that because older
Americans are disproportionately white
and so this would supposedly be
unethical but as a result we ended up
with a mess of a system where lots of
people were inferior legible but
couldn't get appointments so who ended
up with the appointments people who had
a lot of resources who could click
Refresh on websites who could build
little programs to find vacant spots to
could drive hours out of a way to
Upstate New York to some Pharmacy that
had more availability and finally I
worry that this actually is going to
help the worst forces in our politics I
understand my friends worry saying you
know with Donald Trump looking like he
might come back to the White House in
2024 aren't the bigger fish to fry
shouldn't we uh rally around the wagon I
get that instant but in fact it is uh
Trump's victory in 2016 which allowed
many of these ideas to become so
prominent and Progressive and even
facially neutral spaces but it is the
dominance the control that many of these
ideas have over the Democratic party
over mainstream institutions over many
media Outlets that is fueling the anger
which gives Donald Trump a chance to win
back the White House in 2024 so however
different they might be at the
ideological level
in Practical terms one is the yin to be
Abus Yang if we want a decent country we
have to oppose both you know I'm going
to tell a couple stories that I I think
um speak to this I I had dinner with a
guy who was very very senior in the
Hillary Clinton campaign in 2016 and he
said that they ran a closing ad that
showed uh
Muslim woman uh
um like a Latino teenager like a whole
slew of marginalized groups saying uh
hey you know this is the America we want
and he said they actually didn't include
uh any white faces in this ad
um and and they found that this ad uh
actually pushed some folks to vote the
other side like like their base loved it
but it actually turned off some folks
and it struck me as some somewhat
strange that if you were going to put
out an ad that was meant to include the
diversity of America like the Mosaic
like you wouldn't have about pokes who
um you know like I believe remain still
you know like the the majority so that
that was an example I thought that
um like he actually said it's like hey
we we messed up on on that one yeah and
and obviously yeah I agree that we need
parties that stand for multiracial
America that whenever everybody to
belong but that has to mean everybody
and even and purely electron strategic
terms it's really stupid both in 2008
and 2012 a majority of Barack Obama's
voters were white he did better among
non-white groups much better among some
normal groups than among white people
but because white people remain a very
large percentage of America a majority
of the voters that elected Barack Obama
in 2008 in 2012 were white and so to
have its closing argument that says we
want an America that features every
group other than this group it's not
just I think normatively wrong we want a
society in which everybody has a place
it is just strategically incredibly
stupid
foreign
this podcast is sponsored by expressvpn
using the internet without expressvpn is
like not paying attention to the safety
demonstration on a flight most of the
time you'll probably be fine but what if
one day that weird yellow mask drops
down from overhead and you have no idea
what to do it's better to be safe than
sorry that's why I recommend using
expressvpn the network that's used by
high-end corporations for their remote
workers so that everything they do is
hacker proof Anonymous and verified I
like expressvpn because it's easy to use
one click and you're done and you can
access content that you might not be
able to see otherwise from Europe on
Netflix and other providers secure your
online data today by visiting
expressvpn.com Yang that's exp r e s s
vpn.com Yang and you can get an extra
three months free
expressvpn.com yang
yeah I mean heck uh Barack Obama won the
Iowa Democratic caucus and that was
meant to be you know like I was like oh
my gosh like you won in a place that was
I think 94 white at the time
um so there are so many quotes from your
book that I enjoy but uh this is one
that spoke to me I think this is one of
the main ideas of the book The identity
synthesis is a political trap making it
harder to sustain diverse societies
whose citizens trust and respect each
other it is also a personal trap one
that makes misleading promises about how
to gain the sense of belonging and
social recognition that most humans
naturally seek I thought that was very
very powerful thanks yeah and again you
know uh you're Chinese American and I'm
sure your cultural and linguistic
Heritage is important to you I'm Jewish
and informed not religious that is
Meaningful to me
um part of a healthy sense of individual
identity will be those forms of
belonging to a particular group but I
think that the message that we are now
sending young kids in particular and I
really noticed this among the students
that I teach is to say that everybody
seeks recognition in society and they
want to be seen uh as themselves and
that is true I think that's true of
nearly everybody it's true of me it's
probably true of you but the way you
seek bad recognition the way you find
that sense of being seen is to Define
Yourself by the particular intersection
of identities at which you stand and I
think that that is a false promise for
many people whose belonging in a
particular group might be marginal who
perhaps have one parent from one group
and one parent from another group and
another quite seen as fully belonging to
either but but more importantly even if
you're fully a member of that group it
will never actually give you the kind of
recognition which all of us crave which
is that as being individuals as well
probably most people listening if you
have a sibling they're going to share
lots of identity groups with you but
you're not your sibling you love them I
hope hopefully get on with them you
share some interest with them but you're
not identical to them you're
withstanding that you seek in society
the form of recognition you seek from
your parents from your family from
society as a whole goes beyond just that
intersection of identities and so I
worry that we're sending people a
message to seek validation from
something that can be a healthy part of
a self-identity but that can never fully
constitute it if they're actually going
to develop a healthy regard of selves in
a healthy sense of a place in society oh
yeah proud of my Heritage as a child of
immigrants but at the same time
um you know there are issues that affect
all of us I mean when Iran it was on AI
and Automation and I dare say that's
going to affect just about everyone one
reason why your book
I I thought was really uh hard-nosed and
practical was it actually details how a
lot of non-profits uh descended into in
inner turmoil uh and questioning of
their leaders and cultures over the last
number of years I know some of the folks
who run these organizations and some of
them actually say to me that they are
running scared of their own employees
which is by the way not what you want
when you're talking about in many cases
very Progressive not you know
non-profits which theoretically you know
I mean there's a lot of work for them to
do
um that there are some folks I know who
run these organizations who say it's now
their number one Criterion when they're
looking to hire someone is like is this
person going to ask for me to be fired
um X months from now and and that's like
their number one question as their
screening I'm going to suggest that's
deeply unhealthy and a lot of these orgs
are doing very important work and you
hope that their
focused on the work as opposed to
focused on okay are these people going
to come from my job uh down the road
well absolutely
um and you know there's very strong
evidence of these cultural problems
within particularly Progressive
organizations that come from people who
have senior leaders within those spaces
people like Morris Mitchell who uh you
know is the head of a Working Families
party a long time organizer of a
movement for black lives
um who's written very powerfully about
the toxic atmosphere within these
institutions and and one of the reasons
for that is that
we've adopted a set of simplistic ideas
that make many claims uh unfossifiable
so you know in the book again I go
through in the first part of a book
intellectual history of a sophisticated
version of these ideas talking about
people like Michelle Foucault and Edward
Saeed and Gayatri Spivak and Derek Al
and Kimberly Crenshaw and I disagree
with many of them in profound ways
um I have his pet peeve and people say
oh this is like going a little bit too
far I don't think it's going too far you
can't go too far and fighting racism and
sexism and discrimination I'm all in
it's just that that going in the wrong
direction that vision for society is
wrong-headed but be so sophisticated
smart thinkers I also Chronicle of a way
in which we said yes if we become
popularized and sometimes vulgarized in
the form of thinkers like Robin D'Angelo
and IRA max candy and they really uh
have created this unforcifiable fourth
bubble
for D'Angelo a white woman by the way if
you disagree with something she says in
her trainings if you have a different
view of a world if you want to bring
some evidence to the table you're just
demonstrating your white fragility
you're just demonstrating that you're
too uh insecure and probably too racist
to understand the wisdom she's imparting
for ibra makes candy
uh you know there's only racist and
anti-racists there's no in-between
category there's no such thing as being
not racist and any idea or any
institution that has racially desperate
outcomes is by definition racist
including the United States Constitution
so effectively if you don't want to
scrap the United States Constitution you
are racist nothing to be done about that
and that kind of many key and world view
is part of what individuals within these
organizations can weaponize most people
Miss organizations are good decent
people who have genuine ideals for how
to make a better world but like in every
organization there's also some
sociopaths who like to exercise power
over their peers or who are narcissists
who think that they are the best thing
ever and any criticism of them is deeply
unfair and they have now been given
these tools to say if my boss criticizes
me that must be racist that must be
bigoted
and within Progressive organizations and
increases in mainstream organizations
there's no language to stand up to that
and so these few individuals within
these organizations who are often
mentally unwell can use this ideology as
a tool to just destroy by the internal
culture and these deeply damaging ways
yeah I'm going to tell a story about a
non-profit leader who started adding
this language to the job posting saying
we respect people of every background
and ideology uh and then put the word
Republican in the job post you know
Democrats Republicans Independents and
then said that actually ended up
um
screening uh applicants because uh some
folks would be like oh I can't work with
Republicans and and then uh he said hey
this actually improved the culture
because then people who joined would be
like I guess I might have some
Republicans on the team now factually I
think most of his team was um you know
on the other side politically but he was
looking to identify folks who weren't
going to to wind up frankly turning on
their managers in in various ways uh one
of the most powerful quotes in your book
which I obviously enjoyed uh such that
I've I flagged all sorts of things
um Progressive separatism is a dead end
its vision of the future is neither
realistic nor attractive and partial
success a world in which whites do come
to Define themselves by their ethnic
identity yet fail to dismantle the
advantages as that have historically
flowed from it may transport us into the
worst of all possible timelines
uh and this is the concern you
identified earlier which is you say hey
let's separate everyone from uh from
childhood by race and then you have this
majority group of whites that then think
of themselves as uh ethnically White
then you might wind up with a real uh
oppressive environment and in many ways
you call upon the earlier traditions of
universalism which you say you grew up
with and was also very much represented
by the Civil Rights Movement saying we
should all we should treat uh each other
equally as a better approach yeah you
know we write uh Eric Kaufman uh in his
book White Face pointed out that in our
societies now we should very strongly
encouraged with very different forms of
ethnic Pride except for white people
um you know in a way that is evidenced
in this video you talked about from the
Hillary Clinton campaign right
um and his conclusion of that was so
what we should encourage is for white
people to uh have forms of white pride
as well and to uh you know argue for
their interests I respect Kaufman I
think he's a sincere broker but I think
that is precisely the opposite of what
we should do I don't want a society in
which every person is leaning more into
their sort of tribal self-interest and
why it's join the game and say great
we're going to be proud white people
fighting for our interests that sounds
to me like a description of a terribly
deeply divided Society zero-sum battles
for resources which by the way the group
that has historically been most
privileged in the United States is
likely to win because it Remains the
biggest group and it retains a lot of
resources but that is The Logical upshot
of things like these Affinity groups
where teachers come in and split kids up
into groups including the the white kids
and so the question is you know how can
we do better
foreign
glad you're enjoying the podcast if you
really like it hit subscribe and then
YouTube will notify you every time we
have a bang up new guest thank you
we've had this historical debate for a
very long time you know Frederick
Douglass was invited uh by some people
to give a famous speech a speech that
turned out to be famous to become famous
for the 4th of July and he called out
the hypocrisy saying how can you
celebrate the words of a declaration of
independence when there's still slavery
in the United States but he didn't say
therefore because of because we're
hypocritical these words are useless rip
up the Declaration of Independence rip
up the Bill of Rights no he said if you
could truly value those
ideas
those principles then you have to live
up to them by what right are you
excluding me and my fellow
African-Americans from the enjoyment
of these principles that is a
Universalist tradition in American
history but is naive
about Injustice but isn't naive about
obstacles but that points the way to the
right solution this is why Frederick
Douglass fully realizing that Free
Speech allowed people in his day to say
terrible things
called free speech with Dread of tyrants
because it also allowed him and his
fellow abolitionists to argue when it
was very unpopular for the immediate
abolition of slavery that is what
Frederick that is what Martin Luther
King Jr staked his claims on him in
1960s saying that the promissory note
written by the country to African
Americans had turned out to be
fraudulent
but he didn't say let's rip up that
promissory note he said let's make sure
that the bank of Justice actually honors
the promotory note so you know going
back to the three main claims of what
I'm calling the identity synthesis or
what if you like you can call wokeness
these are the three answers to it right
the claims that they make to as a quick
reminder are
racing and sexual orientation of a key
prism for understanding Society
Universal values just pull the wool over
people's eyes we have to rip them up and
make how we treat each other dependent
on the groups of which we're part I
think there is sensible
Universalist responses to each of those
claims and the first one is to say well
look of course race and gender and
sexual orientation matters of course
that's one of the prisms we need to
understand Society but so social class
so is religion so is the individuality
of each of us uh you know whether we act
rightly or wrongly what preferences and
idiosyncrasies we have so is all kinds
of other things we have to let each
situation teach us how to read it rather
than coming to every situation with a
preconceived notion that just knowing
your race and knowing my race we're
going to know what is at stake in this
conversation secondly
of course
we've often failed to live up to
Universal values and neutral rules in
American society but as the example
Frederick Douglass and uh King and so
many others demonstrates the demand to
live up to them the invocation of those
ideas has in fact been a great motor for
historical progress and unlike what
people who belong to the tradition of
the identity synthesis claim we have
been made able to make significant Pros
America today is imperfect but it's much
more just when it was 200 to 100 or 50
years ago and therefore finally
how we make progress is to live up to
those ideals not to get rid of them is
to create a society in which how we're
treated
truly comes to depend Less on the kind
of group of which we're part not because
we ignore injustices but because
together we manage to solve many of them
most people know I I think we should be
doing much more uh to alleviate poverty
um I think this can be something that
folks of any let's call it racial
background uh can agree on and one of
the great policy achievements of the
last number of years was the enhanced
child tax credit that reduced child
poverty from double digits to five
percent and then unfortunately it
expired in 2022 and then shot and then
child poverty shot back up to 12 so
there were maybe five million American
kids who are thrust back into poverty uh
now I feel like poor kids is something
that people of just about any Community
should should be able to say okay like
you know I'm against poor kids I'm for
poor kids having uh enough to eat and
being able to learn and that's an
example of a real
policy goal that I think you can bring
people around so you cite social science
as to okay let's say that I think
divvying people up
um by these immutable traits is not an
ideal path to a successful situation
um so you found all this research as to
when Intergroup contact actually does
improve things and I thought this was
really helpful you said look here are
some of the conditions that Studies have
shown actually improve in a group
relationships maybe they even make you
like people of another race a little bit
more and then think that uh you know we
can all
um get along and get things done so
number one equal status that it's not
like hey you're above or below me it's
like where where on the same team in the
same place number two common goals
things that we can get uh together on
and say you know like we can agree on
this at least and what some of the
things that made me think about this are
teams or military units where you're
like you're you know your goal is to
beat the other team your goal is to uh
to take the objective number three
Intergroup cooperation you have to
actually do things together and then
number four is support from authorities
and Customs so people are encouraged
essentially to be on the team and get
stuff done together uh I I thought that
was actually very helpful thank you yeah
let me say a little bit about each of
these examples right so
um should we care about Universal
welfare state
policies in which we're saying you know
anybody who's in need on certain cases
like Social Security just anybody even
when the affluent is going to get some
kind of benefit or should we target it
targeted Often by racial means saying
because African Americans are more
disadvantaged in the United States we
need special focused programs for
African Americans rather than for
everybody those latter ones have become
very very common in our policy making
recently and I think that they are a
mistake their mistake for pragmatic
reasons because it's much harder to
build those majorities to build those
stable uh uh legislative votes for those
programs as you were saying about the
universal child benefit program that
expired because we couldn't get it
passed through Congress again that
problem is going to become so much more
severe when you have targeted problems
with particular ethnic groups which are
much much less popular but even at the
conceptual levels there is a problem
with the purely dispiritarian account
because even when our African-American
kids are disproportionately likely to be
in poverty a majority of the kids that
are in poverty are likely to come from
other groups the biggest group of
children that is in poverty is white
because there still is a majority of
white people in the country so you're
not actually helping those kids and each
kid that is in poverty should be of
equal concern to us
just as importantly there's a suggestion
that Universal welfare benefits can't
help to redress disparities but that is
actually logically false because if a
disproportionate percentage of kids from
a particular ethnic group are in need
then a policy that helps anybody who's
in need is disproportionately going to
help members of that group the great
black Marxist as it happens uh political
theorist Adobe Jr has uh argued against
the idea of equity what he calls racist
paretarianism by saying you know if you
follow that logic then America would be
just if only 13 of billionaires there's
about 13 of the American population is
is black if only 13 of billionaires were
black so you can still have huge
inequality and stuff have very high
rates of child poverty but we have
Equity that is not the most important
value that we should aim for and then
the other point you make is absolutely
right it's referring back to the most
well-researched well-documented
extensive finding in social psychology
of the last 70 years thousands of
studies showing that so-called
Intergroup contact can have these
positive
impacts which is something we should all
be very happy about what a wonderful
finding but yeah even if I have
prejudices against you or your group
even if you have prejudice against me if
we're in the right kind of situation
we're going to reduce those prejudices
we can build friendships we can
communicate to each other as humans but
the tradition also shows there's clear
constraints on when that happens it
happens in context like a sports team
where within the sports team we have
equal status perhaps you have more money
than I perhaps you come from a social
group that is more respected in general
and that's unfair but on the sports team
we're both players were both treated as
equals we have to work together we're
only going to win if we actually aim for
the same goal and cooperate in this
situation and find if a Coach tells us
whatever beef you have outside of
outside of a team you better get on
that's what I expect of you those
situations allow people to get to know
each other to build trust and then the
locker room or afterwards of a meal they
can say hey
I have these experiences this bad thing
happened to me I have these struggles
and they can open up to each other
instead what we're doing is the opposite
we are separating people out by group
many Elite universities in this country
now are building separate dorms that
were encouraging uh Black and Latino
students to live in so that they're
separated from their other classmates
they send the message that we're not
expected to get along and many American
universities now with Anonymous hotlines
that allow people to report each other
for perceived microaggression
um that is the opposite of what the most
important tradition in social psychology
has taught us about how to actually
encourage people to get along and build
deeper links between them
this podcast is sponsored by Helix sleep
it's a pretty short list of things you
can do that are going to make you
happier healthier more energetic more
productive every single day you know
what's on that list getting the right
freaking mattress and what's the right
mattress for you if you go to Helix
sleep you take their personalized sleep
quiz and they will send you one of 20
unique mattresses made for you and you
alone well not you and you alone like
five percent of people do the math for a
hundred night free trial you can sleep
on this thing for three months it will
keep you cool don't just take my word
for it my kids seek out this mattress in
the house it's the number one rated
mattress picked by GQ and Wired Magazine
this mattress will actually make you
happier healthier and more productive
Helix is offering 20 off all mattress
orders and two free pillows for our
listeners go to helixsleep.com yang this
is their best offer yet and it won't
last long with Helix better sleep starts
now
[Music]
no uh Yasha I'm naturally a Universalist
because I care about poor black kids
white kids Asian kids Latino kids I just
care about poor kids you know I mean uh
I have a couple of kids myself and you
see how
uh
how not having enough to make ends meet
would uh cause for a much more stressful
environment like kids wouldn't be
learning you'd end up having various uh
behavioral problems it breaks my heart
that we actually solved for this for
millions of American kids and then
unsolved for it because of politics uh
and you'd like to think that if you have
a policy Victory like this then people
of every side can get together and
celebrate it
um one reason why I think your work is
so important is that in a two-sided
Universe one of the things that is
happening and I'm just going to suggest
this to folks
um so people get attacked for some kind
of misstatement or failing you know
offense
um uh and then
um they say okay whoever's attacking me
I'm uh clearly not with you so who's
against you I guess I'm with them
um and there are a lot of folks who
actually want great things to happen
they want Society to progress they want
us to be more just more fair
um and we have to try and create a zone
for people to be in where it's like look
I want good things to happen I just
think that this particular ideological
approach is not effective practical
um you know uh something that I
necessarily want to subscribe to but I
also don't want to subscribe to the
folks that are on the other side of this
this thing I mean you know I don't think
that that's right so my some of my work
is trying to create this middle Zone and
I I dare say that there are a lot of
people who would like to join this
middle Zone if we could give them a path
it's one reason why I think your book is
so important because it helps Define for
people why they might be uncomfortable
with certain ideas and then maybe uh an
intellectual home yeah I mean you know
in this debate I feel this very strongly
that a lot of my friends and and
colleagues uh are starting to see how
these ideas are playing out and then
comfortable with them they're
recognizing that they seem to be
wrong-headed but then they switch on
cable news or they look at social media
and the loudest most visible people who
are criticizing these ideas
seem even worse
right where these sort of anti-work
reactionaries who decry anything that is
like as well we teach kids about slavery
in school you work if you think that
there's still racism and sexism in our
society uh you're woke
um you know and when they say well I
don't want to be on the side of these
guys so I guess perhaps I should be woke
you know and what I'm trying to do in
this book is give people the
intellectual tools to understand this
tradition to understand that it really
from the beginning was designed as a
challenge
to uh the kind of hard-nosed uh
Progressive Movement that actually
created positive social change in the
United States
um you know direct battle explicitly
said he wants to abolish with the
defunct Racial equality ideology of a
civil rights movement uh Kimberly
crencho said that the philosophy of
Barack Obama is fundamentally at odds
with critical race Furies so I think a
lot of people even left over in the
center of a liberal or the moderate over
conservative of that matter should be
able to reject these ideas so I have two
goals of this book
the first is to
elevate the argument
that people make against this tradition
to create the language and the force and
the ideas that actually take these ideas
seriously and are then able to explain
why father may be well-intentioned
they're ultimately wrong-headed
uh and I think a lot of people are in
that bird and then I also want to uh
write a book that allows people to feel
genuinely torn to think through this you
say I get why it's so important to fight
against these injustices and some of
these points seem sensible but I also
smell a little bit of a rat so you know
if you're on the first category please
buy this book please read it there's a
lot more than we were able to say in
this conversation I promise it's going
to help you
think through these ideas and argue
against them in a more sophisticated
more honest more effective way and
secondly you know if you have
a brother or a sister-in-law who's a
little bit more on the quote-unquote
work Spectrum who's a little bit more
tempted by these ideas but who you think
is open to serious conversation about it
give the book to them and perhaps you
can have uh this as a conversation
starter perhaps you can actually use
this to to to to have a serious
conversation about these important
issues within your front Circle or
within your family oh yeah sure what a
great vision and ambition for the book
as someone who believes full well that
racism and sexism uh exist but uh and
wants good things to happen for people
um and things that the best path to do
so is the path you suggest which is
making common cause uh with people and
emphasizing our commonalities As
Americans congratulations on this
achievement the identity trap a story of
ideas and Power in our time aside from
buying the book how can people keep up
with you you've also founded a media
company in your time uh yeah so I run a
magazine that stands for many of these
ideas it's a non-profit called
persuasion you can subscribe to us at
persuasion.community and I host a
podcast called the good fight in which
we have uh you know Wonderful guests
like Andrew Young and many many others
uh to have serious conversations about
the most pressing questions of this time
serious conversations about the most
pressing questions of our time congrats
again Yasha and uh it's an awesome book
and I hope that it has the impact that
you envisioned and described thank you
so much Andrew
foreign
[Music]